まとめ買いでお得なので買ってきました
BIGチョコ
これは多分知っている人もいると思うんですけども
「スーパーBIGチョコ」というチョコがあります
ま、名前の通り大きいんですよ、とてもね。
こんなサイズ感です
こんなBIGチョコがあるんですけども
中身がね
中身がスカスカなんですよ。
ま、それはね別に良いとしても
このサイズで"BIG"と名乗られちゃー
たまっちゃもんじゃねーすよ。
このサイズで"BIG"だよ！
おまえらよく考えてみろよ！
世の中にはもっと大きな物もあり
もっと大きなチョコもある。
その中で！！
"BIG"を名乗るってことは、どれだけでかい意味があるのか
わかってるのか！！
オレは問いただしたいよ。
世の中の"BIG"という言葉に
このチョコは果たして"BIG"なのかってことを。
というわけで、今日はこちらのBIGチョコを
100個用意しました。
ま、これだけあったところでも
一個一個は所詮ね、弱きBIGチョコなんですよ。
一人一人はね。
こんなサイズで「スーパーBIG」と名乗られても
オレは「大したことね」と思っちゃうんですよ。
それじゃ"BIG"をナメすぎてる気がしちゃう.
そんなこと、ちょっと小生意気なスーパーBIGチョコなんですけども
オレは考えた。
おまえたちは今日、オレの手で
本当のBIGスターにしてやんよ。な。
おまえたち、わかったか？
BIGチョコ達「わかった！」
ああ、いい返事だ。
おまえたちは本当にスーパーBIGチョコなのか？
BIGチョコ達「違う！！」
そうだろう。おまえたち本当にBIGチョコになりたくないのか？
BIGチョコ達「なりたい！！」
な。そういうこった。
BIGチョコ全てをひとまとまりにして、本当のBIGチョコにします！
おまえら、覚悟はいいか？
行くぞ〜！
BIGチョコ『、、、』
いや、本当にオレはね、これはね、昔から言いたかったよ。
安いんすよ。1個あたり。
あ〜〜〜〜〜〜〜〜！！！！
死んでるぅ〜！！
あ〜〜〜！！
何でこんなことに…。
絶対生き返らせてやるからな。
あ〜、チョコ付いちゃった。
よし、OK！
多分100個あります。
このスーパーBIGチョコを一つにまとめる方法としては
電子レンジを使おうと思っている。
なので、とりあえずこいつらをこのまま
電子レンジに放り込むとしても
サイズがちょっと大きいので
まずは全部二つ折りにして
ちょっと小さめのコンパクトサイズにします。
でやぁ〜〜〜〜〜〜！！！！
(切り裂き音)
は！
タンマ。多分一回、
待った！重っ！！
もう入れれるだけ入れてみようか。
よしっ！イケるイケる。
全部入りませんでした。
すいませんでした！！
ま、でも、多分これだけのねBIGチョコがあれば
こいつらもね、もう感動するぐらいなおっきなチョコができると思います。
では早速、温めていきましょう
大丈夫だ、チョコだから。
食べ物入れてるから。
爆発とかさすがにしないと思うんですけどね。
ちょっとこちらとしては怖いですね。
待って！なんかヤバい！
なんか目に。目が痛い！目が痛い！
(え、待って！なんかヤバい！なんか待って！
良くないガスが出てる！)
ちょっと良くないガスが出ているみたいです。
開けます！ごめんなさい！ちょっと休憩！ダメ！
な、な、な？何？何が起きてる？
何が起きてるんだ？
なんか吸ってはいけないや…ものが出ている気がします。
とりあえず救出します！
どうやって出そうかな。
いや、怖っ。熱っ！
まずひとまとまりになってるかなってないかってところが不安だから
ゆっくりでいいよ。
ここら辺も完全に一体化して合体してます。
よしっ。
待て。
どうよ？
わ！わ！わ！わ！わ！
いろいろ試したんですけど
今回は無理でした。
今、とりあえず全部粉々になってる状態までもってたんで、
何かこれを使っていいメニューがあったら教えてください。
あの、スナック力が強すぎて、溶かそうとも溶けないんですよね、チョコが。
何かいいメニューがありましたら教えてください。
お待ちしております。